في بيان مشترك عقب قمه جمعت قاده دول
عصيان والصين بعد كل من رابطه عصيان وصينا
المجتمع الدوليه لتعزيز الامن الغذائي
بصفته حقا من حقوق الانسان قال زعماء هذه
الدول ان التغير المناخيه والصراعات
الجيوسيه واضطرابات سلاسل التوريد شكل
التحديات خطيره للامن الغذائي العالمي
اتفق الزعماء على ضمان الامن الغذائي
لسكان المنطقه لذينه يزيد تعدادهم عن
ملياريه شخص وتحقيق الاستقرار في الاسواق
الغذائيه الاقليميه ووضعين مثال يحاول
كانت الامن الغذائي العالمي اكدت دول
مجموعه اسيا على انهم مشاركون نشيطون
ومساهمون مهمونه في الامن الغذائي العالمي
والاقليبي ومستعدونا لمواصله تعزيز
الاتصالات السياسيه والتبادلات والتعاون
لضمان الامن الغذائي